10.
9.
8.
7.
(TOGETHER) 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Ghostwriter, Beyond the Page.
Great.
You're here.
Welcome back to Ghostwriter, Beyond the Page episode 2.
Today we're going to become explorers and journey
through the lush world beneath the tropical canopy
of The Jungle Book.
However, I think our journey is going
to be delayed a little bit because Donna
has misplaced her bullet journal somewhere in her bedroom.
I hope she finds it soon because she
needs it to write her story.
So let's check in and see how she's doing.
I know I had it when I was writing last night.
Aha!
I knew it was in here somewhere.
There's so many important things in here.
I don't know what I would do without it.
Hey!
Speaking of important stuff, I finished my character
descriptions.
OK.
Check this out.
A smart young girl with an amazing eye for color,
patterns, all things fashion.
They say write what you know, right?
She's talented at sewing and weaving,
but she has a hard time feeling like she fits in,
especially when her sporty older brother treats her
like a little kid in front of all their friends.
While I was brainstorming I thought
there should be a reason why Sapphire my character's name,
is so good at making threads.
And then it hit me.
Sapphire should be a spider.
And her older brother Spelman is a star soccer player,
because with eight legs, he can really kick.
The only thing is the world of a spider
is so different than mine.
I mean, for them, everything is literally larger than life.
I hope I can do her justice.
Here, I even drew a picture of her.
Where?
Well, that came out of nowhere.
This has to be Ghostwriter with more help for my story.
All right, let's see.
Where?
Well, good thing I already found out where my journal was.
Oh, what in the world?
What are you looking for, my friend?
Mowgli, what a nice surprise.
Clearly, Ghostwriter knows I need help.
Donna, it is good to see you.
You, too, Mowgli.
Where are you?
I'm exploring the jungle, searching for a new place
to call home.
Oh, so you're not with your wolf family.
No.
It has become important for me to find
a place of my own, a new home.
My wolf family will always love me and be there for me,
and I will always be a part of the pack.
But I must now spread my wings and find a new place
where I belong, somewhere that protects my wolf family
and my human family from Shere Khan,
and somewhere I can truly become the human cub I'm meant to be.
Wow.
So it sounds like it's important to find a place that you
feel like you belong.
Yes, exactly.
I think you can't really know who you are if you
don't know where you belong.
That makes sense.
Well, I don't want to keep you from your search.
Yes, I must continue before the sun dips below the trees.
Take care, Donna.
OK.
I really think I get this one.
What Mowgli said must be true.
If where is so close to who, I need to figure out the where
for Sapphire.
I have to create a setting.
I forgot that Mowgli forges his own path
at the end of the book, but let's see what happens first.
"Ow!"
Mowgli rolled over and was poked in the back by a branch.
He opened his eyes and sighed.
He'd hope to wake up safe and snuggled between his sleeping
brothers, warm in their fur.
Instead, he was exactly where he was the night before.
Out in the middle of the jungle.
Chased off by his own pack.
Twigs and branches from the tent he'd made
tumbled onto his head.
Mowgli gave a sniff and rubbed his arm across his nose.
[MONKEYS CHIRPING]
"Why the long face, friend?"
a voice chittered overhead.
"Yeah, why so sad?"
called another voice.
Mowgli looked up.
"Who's there?"
"Oh, everyone."
"And no one."
"Just us, you see.
The monkeys!"
[MONKEYS CHIRPING]
What in the world?
Sure enough, several little monkeys with wide grins
peered down at him from the trees.
They dangled on matted, wildly spiked tails.
Mowgli had seen them swinging through the treetops
and nibbling on sweet bananas.
He'd wanted to play with them, but his mother disapproved.
She called them "little troublemakers"
Mowgli felt a pang in his heart at the thought of his parents,
then shook it away.
They weren't here now.
They told him to leave.
They didn't have the right to decide what he did anymore.
As soon as he thought that, he felt ashamed.
No.
Being mad at his parents wasn't the answer.
This was Shere Khan's fault.
"Cheer up!" one of the monkeys chirped,
handing him a ripe mango.
Mowgli was surprised and a little pleased
to have someone looking out for him.
"Yeah!
Cheer up!" called another monkey.
"We think you're cool!"
"How did you make that log cave?
Looks quite snuggly-- eek!"
The first monkey nearly toppled out of the tree
as a large, furry brown paw knocked the trunk.
"Oops."
A shaggy sloth bear lumbered into view.
"I must have slipped."
"Baloo!"
Mowgli exclaimed happily.
"Why are you here, too?"
Along with Bagheera, Baloo was Mowgli's other best friend.
Baloo scratched his round belly.
"Bagheera was worried about you wandering off,"
he explained, patting Mowgli's head.
"I showed up while you were sleeping last night.
He left me to watch you until he gets back."
"Bagheera shouldn't worry," Mowgli said,
but he was secretly glad his friends were with him.
"I'm fine.
Don't you have better things to do?"
"Good friends never leave you alone,"
Bagheera called from behind them.
The panther sauntered up and carefully dropped a banana
from between his teeth.
"Eat that.
You're a growing cub.
Now, why are you talking to the monkeys?"
"They seem nice," Mowgli said, breaking up
a chunk of the banana and walking with his friends.
"They gave me this mango."
Baloo sniffed.
"They seem nice for now.
Just you wait.
Listen, Mowgli.
We've taught you a lot of the ways of the jungle, right?"
"Right!"
"And we've never steered you wrong, right?"
"Of course!"
Mowgli said firmly.
"You've been my teachers for years.
You guys know everything about the jungle."
"That's right."
Bagheera purred proudly.
I never realized how much The Jungle Book
focuses on finding home.
From the wolf pack to the monkey kingdom to the village,
there are a lot of important places along Mowgli's journey.
I've got some thinking to do about where
my character will live.
Maybe she'll be trying to find it, just like Mowgli.
Well, let's dive right in.
If you want to dive deeper into the Ghostwriter world,
be sure to read The Jungle Book.
And then when you're finished, the Jungle
Ghost section of the activity guide.
And of course, be sure to check in with the Ghostwriter gang
on Apple TV+ for episodes of the show.
So thank you for exploring with me today.
And I can't wait for you to come back
next time when we're going to see what Donna
and Ghostwriter are up to next.
Bye bye.